this was a story that we were tracking
last week uh we talked about last week
for the one show where i could talk
um eli ehrlich is a trans activist an
influencer who it was revealed by libs
of tick tock posted on instagram a few
months ago announcing a plan to send
prescription hormone pills to anyone who
wants them across the country including
minors
in circumvention of state states that
are outlawing uh these drugs for kids
also in circumvention of like every law
of every federal law you can't you can't
just take prescription pills and mail
them to somebody um much less can you
organize a distribution network for the
illegal
uh distribution and dealing of
prescription drugs which is what eli
earlier confessed to doing
and um
and it turned out that erlick had uh
talked about this plan many times before
we played the youtube video with a sort
of a confession which has now been
deleted there were other instagram posts
as well then there and then there were
these um
other twitter posts which libs of tick
tock dug up a couple of days ago
just to show you how often ehrlich has
talked about this this is on twitter
this is in violation of twitter's rules
by the way of course like you're not
allowed on any of these platforms
according to their rules you cannot use
their platforms to facilitate the
commission of a crime
and so erlich posted in may says as i've
said before if anyone needs hormones who
can't get access message me i have a
network with years of extra doses this
is only a band-aid solution to an
ongoing political problem but we can't
rely on the state or medical
institutions to keep us safe and healthy
um update we now have a full network of
trans people with prescriptions for
testosterone shots and testo gel too we
refused to let texas prevent trans youth
from accessing care that was in february
in also february after reading about the
sickening new texas directive against
trans youth i will personally mail
estradiol
and spirano lactone to anyone worried
about the government coming after your
kids f you greg abbott okay so this is
in testosterone by the way a schedule
three controlled substance
but it's being announced on twitter on
youtube on instagram
this illegal drug distribution thing
plan
now i recommended last week reporting
this to the dea and if you haven't done
that yet then uh now i know it's the dea
the
the chances that they'll do anything are
relatively slim you should report it
anyway and if you haven't yet go to the
go to the da's website it's very easy to
go google it find the tip line and um
and
send the tip in
um
ehrlich also lives i believe in new york
city so if you want to contact local law
enforcement if you haven't done that yet
i know a lot of people have you could
contact local law enforcement let them
know they have a confessed drug dealer
running this prescription drug ring in
the city maybe they should want to do
something about that i also mentioned
that ehrlich is a phd candidate at
university of california santa cruz now
i said last week that i'd give the
leadership there a day to respond and to
tell us what steps they would take to
address this before i started giving out
their contact information well they
never did address it and i was out for a
week
so they actually ended up getting a week
and now it's time to escalate
um
university of california santa cruz is a
public university
these
officials have no right
to ignore this issue
they just don't have the right to do it
you can't ignore it
okay you're a public institution there's
a confessed drug dealer sending drugs to
kids
at your school you can't just ignore the
public when we're concerned about it
um they have to tell us what they're
going to do so here's what we're going
to do first of all i want to put up on
the screen we have a an organizational
flow chart for uh uc santa cruz i want
you to take a look at that maybe take a
screenshot of it or something
these are and you see some email
addresses there as well but there you
see
uh all of the the whole leadership at uc
santa cruz you see all their names there
and these are all people that we should
be reaching out to to ask what are they
going to do about this
a phd candidate has confessed
to a highly illegal
prescription drug distribution ring
targeting miners what are you going to
do about it is the question
but we should start i think
with
the chancellor of the university who is
cynthia larive
and we'll put her uh contact information
up there now you can email her
chancellor
ucsc.edu you could call her 831-459-4291
i would start with her i mean she's at
the top of the hierarchy she's the
leader so she should be the first one we
contact
there's also peter beale who has his
pronouns of course listed on his on his
profile on the site he's the vice
provost and the dean of graduate studies
so this is a phd candidate also a good
person to contact 831-459-3336
[Music]
so i want you to call and email these
two officials at the university and ask
them what they are doing to con to
investigate the confessed drug dealer at
the university confessed felon
if they continue to ignore us
next i will find the board of trustees
and i will find the donors at the school
and we're going to start reaching out to
them
and after that
if we still don't get a response then
we're going to show up there with a
crowd of people
i'll come there personally because you
cannot ignore us
that is not an option
if this was anybody else
if this was not a trans person if this
wasn't hormone prescription pills but
some other prescription being
distributed
as part of this illegal drug dealing
ring
um
we all know the university would have
kicked this person out of the school by
now
instead they want to give them
you know instead it's it's uh it's well
we're gonna we're gonna give all not
even benefit of the doubt it's just all
the
it's it's a it is a get out of jail free
card literally
but that's not going to be acceptable
so again what are you going to do about
a university you have to tell us
i will not allow you to ignore us you
cannot it is not an option
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
that wall show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this youtube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts